Shafiqa is eight months pregnant.
She was forced to flee her home in Myanmar.
During her escape,
she says she was raped by soldiers.
When Shafika eventually made it to the Rohingya refugee camp,
here, in Cox's Bazar in Bangladesh, the 25-year-old realized she was pregnant.
The baby growing inside of her – a result of her rape.
This is Shafika's story.
Shafika fled her village in Rakhine state along with her husband and their two children.
They left in the dead of night with nothing but the clothes on their backs.
Soldiers from the Myanmar military first separated Shafiqa from her husband. And then they took away her youngest child
Shafiqa had lost a child and
didn't know if her husband was alive or dead.
She and her 4-year-old daughter were captives of the Myanmar military.
Shafika says the soldiers would take the women up to a mountain to rape them.
Even though she was weak Shafiqa saw an opportunity and took it.
At least 10,000 Rohingya were killed in Myanmar in 2017.
More than 700,000 have escaped to Bangladesh. And during the Myanmar military's campaign of massacre and rape,
women's bodies became a terrain of conflict.
Shafiqa is not alone.
Although there are no specific figures of how many pregnancies have occurred because of these rapes,
at least 2,700 survivors of sexual and gender-based violence have received help in the camps.
Shafika made it to Ghundhum refugee camp after a treachorous five-day journey.
Here, she was reunited with her husband 20 days later.
More than 60 Rohingya babies are born in the refugee camps in Bangladesh every day.
The conditions for pregnant women in the camps are dire,
especially for survivors of sexual violence.
Shafiqa Is denied citizenship in Myanmar. She'll raise her baby in this camp when it's born.
Despite the perilous conditions
she and her newborn child will have to face in the world's largest refugee camp, Shafika will not go back to Myanmar.